a two-month-long nationwide search for a
newborn that is now more urgent than
ever more than 200 officers scouring
allotments in Brighton after the baby's
parents were arrested nearby police
aware every second May count they have
been further arrested on suspicion of
gross negligence manslaughter and that
they remain in custody at police
stations in Sussex the baby was not with
them and we have not found the baby at
yet how hopeful are you that the baby is
still alive given the time frame you're
working against here as time progresses
as the weather is it is closing tonight
as it was last night in terms of
the cold the coldness and the impact
that would have on a baby clearly the
risk is getting higher and we have to be
open to the fact that this may not end
in the way we would like but we need to
remain hopeful Constance Martin and Mark
Gordon have been on the Run since
January disappearing with their baby
soon after it was born sleeping rough to
evade police and keeping their faces
covered on CCTV but last night they were
seen in this shot by a member of the
public who called 999 within minutes
they were arrested
okay what did you see last night so
about like
um 15 police cars just like whiz up the
road
um I think a helicopter loads of sirens
um they were just like continuous and it
was like one every minute and it was
just really weird I think like after the
fifth one we were like what's going on
but despite the huge police presence
they found no sign of where the couple
was staying detectives have started
questioning the couple but say they've
gained no further information from that
on where their baby may be so for now
the search continues here but police
also haven't ruled out the possibility
the couple may have handed their child
to somebody else
even the child's gender hasn't been
divulged by the parents and it's yet to
receive any medical attention this is
Paramount because this is a child who is
non-mobile really vulnerable would need
uh their dependence to feed them to care
for them and if they don't have their
primary parents around then that is a
big concern and the more time that
passes the more concerns grow as police
consider widening their search across
the South Downs either Bennett Sky News
Brighton